hey everybody out there this is John
Cena I'm gonna be doing a wired
autocomplete without further at you
let's I do this okay so here's how it
works
the question is who John Cena who let
John Cena fly the helicopter whoever did
that was a poor management decision who
is John Cena's father this is where the
plot thickens are you ready for this
because I John Cena have a father named
John Cena little known internet fact I'm
not a junior is John Cena's team well
that's a group of folks just like a band
of minstrels that travel the universe
they play a song it's a very trumpet
based it goes something like Pratt Pratt
Pratt that's my team
who does John Cena look like I fancy
that he looks like a character named
John Cena who is found often on WWE
programming I think we have a striking
resemblance I'll let you decide who is
John Cena wrestling sometimes he's like
this sometimes he's like this and
sometimes he's like this and sometimes
he's like this and that's the four
phases of John Cena wrestling google
auto-complete completed next what John
Cena let's see what Google had to say
about what is John Cena's diet good
choices and folks you out there know
what good bad choices are like well tell
me what those are come on overindulgence
is the key to to dietary room what ours
John Cena's shoes so they're like a
peanut butter style I had to really
grease the ends of my toes to get into
these my feet are swollen thumping what
does John Cena's finishing move it
usually is are you okay and then I go
get a sandwich and call my mom what is
John Cena's horoscope in my future is a
wonderful animated movie called
Ferdinand which you're all gonna go see
I know horoscopes are usually general
someone was very specific and I wonder
why
what is John Cena's hometown I hailed
for the mean street of West Newbury
Massachusetts in it have you ever been
to West Newbury you know what I'm
talking about there's two streets
there's Main Street and
people street there's a dump in West
Newbury and it's on Maple Street so you
wanna stay on Main Street wired
autocomplete next phase of Google what
John Cena what does John Cena look like
well he is a man with a deformed human
face what was John Cena's longest title
reign well I've the been the champ of
being stupid for 40 years let me see
what if John Cena played Minecraft well
I would build worlds that's what would
happen if I played Minecraft what did
John Cena play in football well that
answers simple football it's a sport
that all players play on there's
positions I think the question should be
what position did John Cena playing
football so I'll answer this question
football what is the John Cena potato
salad joke there is a small large group
of folks out there who think that I'm
rather bland kind of like potato salad
it's bland it's something you sit down
at a barbecue for the sake of having
another food I guess it's better to be
called potato salad then a steaming heap
of bull so what are you gonna do next
more does John Cena so these are four
answers from the Google machine of does
John Cena does John Cena still wrestle
in 2017 well these are the final days of
2017 so yes yes next does John Cena sing
ISM theme songs yes I wrote and produced
and created a theme song done with Tom's
new franchise blow up shot and then
can't see me my time in case you forgot
I fell off I'm still hot knock your
shell off so you know the rest does John
Cena do cardio cardio is an exercise
that increases your heart rate so yes
two and a half minutes at a time I do
cardio does John Cena have a youtube
channel their channels on YouTube where
you can see John Cena but there's no
specific John Cena YouTube channel
top searches of do Bulls first one do
Bulls have utters I would speculate that
they do because I have I've nipples do
Bulls hate red
I think they hate agitation I don't
think it's a color thing so I think they
hate agitation do poles move yes that
sounds like this Oh
[Music]
DuBose qualify for bonus depreciation we
all know about this I'm not gonna bore
you with commodities class but sadly
enough I do think that those qualify for
bonus depreciation do Bulls wear bells a
bell wearing Bowl is a belly laugh it's
boisterous and beautiful you should take
a bespoke blow with a bell do Bulls eat
apples yes they do I'd like to think
they'd eat anything but a grain based
snacks some sort of grass but I think
apples should and could be in their diet
wired autocompletes next phase where is
John Cena's where's John Cena's house
well home is where the heart is guys and
right now my heart's with you so you're
out there listening welcome home it's
been a wonderful journey I'm glad you're
back you wanna make your self a sandwich
I'll turn reruns on your favorite
program on ok great
no problem and put the toilet seat down
where is John Cena right now I kind of
already answered that question and we'll
go to the next one thank you where is
John Cena's gym I don't know that way
where is John Cena from before you
address this guys I'm from my mom
that's how creation is made whereas John
Cena's family from essentially my family
is from a long line of people that
produced people and that that's how we
be became to be this is John Cena for a
wired autocomplete session adios